isn't he's so bad I'm so sorry I
apologize to all British people in
advance hi I'm Jack Wallace and I'm a
dialect coach here in Hollywood today
I'm gonna be teaching different people
the Yorkshire dialect I just learned
there is a Yorkshire accent I know
nothing about the Yorkshire accent and
I'm so nervous I know that it's British
where would you use the Yorkshire accent
like what like what ok what I mean I've
recently watched a fleabag
most days I like london-based ok that's
one of the things that I feel like us
Americans are really bad at is
discerning the different types of
British accents like I've never heard of
a Yorkshire accent before do you watch
any British shows at all Game of Thrones
Geoff oh yeah Game of Thrones sure yes
so Ned Stark
he is from Sheffield which is in
Yorkshire okay I'm gonna be here today
I'm not gonna die though so yeah yeah
well well we don't know TBD I might die
generally there is a kind of north/south
divide when it comes to accents in
England and Yorkshire is in the north
where is like cockney from cogniat from
London which is in the south
ok so lose London we're not in London
anymore we are no longer in Atlanta
we're heading on the train north to
Yorkshire let's take a look at some
signature Yorkshire sounds this is gonna
require a lot of finessing just so we're
clear
so what is the first letter of the
alphabet a excellent and if you were to
stay in any way to make it British would
you need to know I say a you say a
basically the same we're in this poem do
you see that sound waves chambers
absolutely wake yeah I think that's it
I'm guessing there's a trick here in
Yorkshire it's different we want to keep
the sound the same length but stay on
the first half so instead of going a we
want to go a yeah so we get waves waves
where we want to keep it the same length
if we don't keep it the same length it
becomes Webb's we just want it like
waves waves yeah wave wave wave
Wow Wow Wow okay yes so that's a key to
Yorkshire specifically that's
signature sounds so if you get that
sound and a couple of others people
automatically think oh he's northern
slash from Yorkshire oh that's what
they're gonna think about me for sure in
your master's chambers in your master's
chambers in tenacious good little
Jamaican but that's good waves waves
chambers wick waves waves chambers work
like Mel B yeah yeah please from here oh
okay that makes so much sense okay if
that helps
so the opposite of down is up we get a
little further north into Yorkshire and
it flips completely and becomes up so
you have wake us wake us we will wake us
up
gosh I really want to get this down I
want to be good at this you're terrible
mi you're doing great you're in the
letting process you are taking to it
like a duck to water
I love that duck to water so what letter
comes after n Oh in your natural one how
many sounds are in that sound Oh
- exactly Oh Oh in Yorkshire it becomes
one steady sound learn yeah I think the
only O's we have are combing blown and
blows so we want them to be combing
blown and blows blown yep blows combing
the white hair of the way Wow
when I said combing I I don't sound like
Sean Bean but I'm like I hear hear his
voice say the lonely goat the lonely
goat yeah see that I feel like I'm
getting vaguely Irish like when Lee
coming yep blown nose not bad it's gonna
get a little French in the blaze so in
your normal accent what comes after h-hi
mm-hmm and we want it I said yeah it's
hotter I I riding riding trying to find
that stuff if they have not in a place
that you normally start yeah a starting
point here is like them
middle of my normal accent yeah exactly
right have been riding seaward on the
waves waves calming white hair of the
waves blue and back now all you need to
do is just have a little confidence with
it fake it till you make it okay I'll
get there oh I'm gonna keep working on
this all right here we go
I have seen them writing seaward on the
waves combing the white hair of the
waves blown back when the wind blows the
water white and black we have lingered
in the chambers of the sea
bye see girls weathered and seaward red
and brown till human voices wake us and
we drown I'll take a b-minus I tried did
my best yeah nailed it
[Music]